you're going to die one day I just  wanted to remind you  stand clear  this is me Mark Manson and I wrote a  book  it's about self-esteem  you deserve to be special and unique and  extraordinary  actually that's bull  [Applause]  [ __ ]  it's about positivity  down  you go on social media and you feel like  a loser  the message is that a better life is  about more more and more making a lot of  money might make you feel good but it  won't make your kids love you  our brain is kind of playing this game  with us  to give a [ __ ] about everything a nicer  job low fat milk SPF and ozone social  media  then we'll live happily ever after  just knocked out there's only a few  things in life that are ever worth  giving about  [Music]  easier if I could just hit you with six  easy steps to life success but to really  get into this stuff you've got to feel  it and to feel it  I guess I'm gonna have to dig up some  old painful [ __ ]